mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
suppose two lines intersect in the
interior of a circle
if the measure of this arc of the circle
is equal to 80 degrees and the measure
of this arc of the circle is equal to
140 degrees what is the value of this
angle x where the two lines intersect
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
the key is constructing a cord of the
circle between the two intersecting
lines
let's see why this helps
consider this 80 degree arc
notice between this chord and a line
we've constructed an inscribed angle of
the circle
therefore the measure of this inscribed
angle will be one half of 80 degrees
which is equal to 40 degrees
similarly for the other arc we've
constructed an inscribed angle of the
circle
therefore the measure of this angle will
be equal to 70 degrees
putting these two facts together we now
consider the two intersecting lines and
this constructed triangle
this angle x is an exterior angle of the
triangle therefore its value will be
equal to 70 degrees plus 40 degrees
which is equal to 110 degrees
another way of seeing this is that the
remaining angle in the triangle is equal
to 70 degrees to get a total sum of 180
degrees and then x is equal to 180
degrees minus 70 degrees which is equal
to 110 degrees and that's our answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]